the technology is a tool the technology
has to it's an answer it's not a
question so defining the questions
defining what it is you're looking for
that's what drives me
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to be talking about connected
devices in the world of cyber security
it's important meet iran find the ceo
and co-founder of nanolog security he
was a consultant to imagine that was
sold to snapchat and was the co-founder
and ceo of ore that was acquired in
2015. he was a consultant just imagine
that was sold to snapchat and was the
co-founder and ceo of veri that were
acquired in 2015 he was a senior
consultant to tel aviv university
nanoloc science center and singular
university in beijing china's mit
iran was also the co-founder of on eden
that was sold to the formula group and
created five comedy shows among them the
highly successful show the leash
eran fine welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you i'm very well and i'm
already looking forward for only 20
minutes
feels so short we have so much to speak
about
we have way too much to speak about
you're absolutely worried about that but
but let's start with with two things
first of all where are you right now it
looks beautiful
um it's our offices we are about 20
minutes north of tel aviv
um we decided that we wanted some um
an experience which is slightly
different from the big towers and so on
so forth
um that impacts immediately on the
nature of the people team but coming to
to work in the company and the dna of
the company um there are birds around us
it's nice although i have to say that uh
we just concluded the financing round
and since we're growing we have to go
into a more conventional location soon
well that's amazing and yeah actually i
had to ask you to put on headphones
because there are so many birds around
you which are amazing for the daily work
for podcast recording unfortunately it's
a little bit harder
but but this before we get into nanolock
and what you're doing with security for
iot connected devices take me through
the journey of of landing in japan after
16 hours in the wrong city and the wrong
day i have to do that story i have to
okay um
so it's a 16 hours flight and two hours
by by bus that's the way it works
um
and you know i've been going to the same
city over and over and over we had a
customer there so automatically i went
to that exact same exact same city not
knowing that i'm supposed to be in a
different city with a different customer
in a different hotel
i was very very embarrassed i felt
extremely stupid the people at the hotel
were very kind to me they were i think
they felt sorry for me for being who i
am
but um
it was
it was okay being in japan is so lovely
so even if it's the wrong city if it's
the wrong company i've managed but it
felt very stupid
but it was also the wrong day let's not
forget about that because it's
awesome
they're so polite and they will never
embarrass you so they were doing all the
right moves but just on the wrong day
um i and here is a story that still
resonates about eight years later so
it's you know it was it was an issue
i love it
so iran walk me a little bit through
your experience in the cyber security
space you you've done quite a lot of
work there
and and we'll get to that nanolock and
talk about iot connected devices but
walk me through some of the big
milestones in your career and and what
led you now to to deciding to open your
company analog
so
it's a journey and and it was not cyber
beforehand it was other companies so
before nanoloc i had the pleasure and
privilege of being a consultant
to the nanoscience technology center of
the television university and in other
organizations and so on so forth and i
came across quite a lot of interesting
technologies one of them
triggered my interest and i thought it
would be a great solution to the market
obviously i was wrong by the way
so we came up with this idea we thought
this is what we're going to do um we put
it in front of decision makers in the
u.s intelligence community they smiled
politely and gently said okay
like this but something we can use
now and not 20 years from now
but it was
it was a good feedback that led us to to
get analog
price and i like i had the pleasure of
starting my own two companies and
selling one of them
and so the journey didn't start with
cyber but at a certain point in time we
realized that we are
probably solving a big problem in a
market that is
materializing as we speak so that was
the
point here's a great technology and the
right market is the cyber world that in
a second you'll have
billions of devices lacking of resources
computational power energy and so on so
forth and nobody can serve them so that
was the point that we took it into the
cyber world
right so we're going to be talking about
obviously connected devices iot and the
world emerging around us whether whether
we are aware of it or like it or not is
becoming ultra connected i remember
during one of my army courses they
brought us somebody from i think the
technion or ben gurion to talk about how
you can now do cyber on fat on ceiling
fans which was completely mind-blowing
and mind-boggling
before we dive into nanolog specifically
and what you do paint me a picture of
the of the of you know where we are in
the world in terms of connected devices
where we were and where we're headed
sure
um we're becoming more and more
connected whether it's the internet
proprietary networks or people coming
with usb that's also connectivity to
have more and more ways for devices to
communicate with people or communicate
among themselves
so you can start with 5g and and so on
so forth and we have more and more
connected devices because you have
machines that need devices to support
them and provide them with data sensing
and so on support so the world is
becoming more and more connected if you
have data in you can have data out if
you have data in to be corrupted data if
you have data out that could be
corrupted data so
everything from ai and machine learning
systems to
the water industry to the electricity
industry to wherever connectivity is the
basics and the fundamental part of or
our fundamental part of their existence
and the way they operate
more devices more connectivity that's
one
uh one path the second one um
lack of trust
so you have more connected devices they
are not in your possession they are not
necessarily next to you
sorry if you have a meter it's in the
street it's in the field it's not in
your protected i.t environment and then
somebody can touch it physically then
one of your employees which is not
necessarily one of your
service providers
can harm it so it's numbers connectivity
and vast distribution beyond the horizon
beyond the hill beyond your protected
i.t environment these are the trends
right and as and with that trend talk to
me a little bit about the growing
cyber security trend that is sort of
parallel and accompanying this trend
so
uh well it's always about english
acronyms so it's the movement from it to
ot
from information technology into
operational technology so
um you have phenomenal companies
protecting the intellect the information
technology the assets the the servers
the data
but when you have billions of devices in
the field
if those devices doesn't function you
have an ot issue your operational
aspects um are shying or are changing
if you're a business relying on its
operations like a energy company like an
electricity company like an industrial
company if your ortiz harmed
you're doomed
so the trend in cyber as we see that
from our
narrow world view
is number one there's more and more risk
at the ot side
ot is a
interesting combination of legacy
systems
a new design system so you have a
it's a chaos it's a bevel uh tower of
devices
that you don't have anything in common
if in i.t you have any commonality you
say it's a window it's running on this
machine fine ot is just one big chaos
right and so
with that growing concern
is this something that you know people
are really being concerned with right
now or is this a concern that is going
to be more relevant
soon from the perspective now of an
entrepreneur who's speaking to a lot of
the people that are managing these
connected devices sure well it starts
from the definition of people is my mom
concerned no and she's people by the way
my mom is not concerned and people with
with fans in their in their houses are
not concerned
are
people working in the electricity
company water industry
uh colonial pipeline in the us concern
yes they are um
are the people with
holding or working with a bunch of field
engineers that they didn't hire and
recruit that taking care of their device
field devices yes they're very much
concerned is that a mainstream among you
know
nine people not billion people in the
world no but for the specific industry
of connected industrial and energy
devices it's a big thing
right maybe you know before we get into
the technology
for those that don't are not yet
concerned and and i am concerned and i
think that anybody listening to this
episode should be concerned
what are some examples of potential use
cases for how cyber can interact with
ot devices around the world sure
well let's start with the fact that a an
engineer with access to smart meters can
do something which is not
is a fraudulent or a theft attack you
can manipulate the meter
to do something different so the bill
goes down
the bill goes down if the bill goes down
the consumer is happy the electricity
company or the water company are not
happy so that's a cyber and fraud uh
that's the fraudulent and theft attacks
on the other side if you're looking into
uh
um industrial machines like what
happened in honda or tsmc
one can the industrial machines
or the production floor and ask for a
fee so we have all the way from
uh something from the outside to front
and soft and lastly at the state level
uh or nation level attacks i can
the
in i can the infrastructure i
can surge the
energy consumption i can um the
water
consumption and water distribution
so it varies from a frozen theft to a
ransomware attack by cyber criminals to
state level events that can the
country itself
so so the bottom line is that we should
be concerned
that's i think that the baseline that
we're setting here
aware concern is is being aware and you
know uh coming from my very jewish
family i come from we are constantly
concerned so we're working with this to
be to be only aware
and not
um but yes the the there's a motivation
there's an ability and it's it's a war a
constant battle between the two
interests
so
nanolock you're coming in you understand
this problem you understand the emerging
world it's a market that obviously as
time passes by is exponentially more and
more relevant and i don't believe we've
seen mainstream attacks yet that are
prevalent to the day-to-day of people
which makes it mainstream but but that's
inevitable right and i believe that if
you go to your website in the you know
one of the first sentences that you see
there is that you know things are
vulnerable that's just the way that it
is there's no way around that
how does nanolock fit into this
narrative that we're describing here
there were quite a lot of attacks that
did
influence day-to-day lives of many
people
um were fortunate not to be a fact but
many by by many of them here in israel
but things happen
number two the assumption we came up
with is
there so many vulnerabilities we cannot
solve vulnerabilities because the
vulnerability of a device can start by
michael choosing the password one two
three four michael which i hope you
didn't
um
but
oh yeah i'm sorry for revealing that but
you have a variety of devices a variety
of
um
of um
do not stop cannot be stopped what you
can stop is conversion of
vulnerabilities into an attack
or into a cyber incident
that's understanding number one
understanding number two is
it's a very complicated world and
probably the adversaries are smarter i
they they're ahead of us
so we we try to find what is common and
what is simple
and what is
the
most the last quality last or the first
line of defense
every attack that has to be synchronized
is looking for a beachhead inside the
device every attack
you want to be persistent inside the
device either way otherwise a restart
will take the attack away so you want to
be there right in a persistent manner
you can call it apt advanced persistent
threats
understanding number one number two
persistency in a device achieved by
putting something inside the
non-volatile memory the flash
so we develop a technology that is
looking on the communication between the
processor the cpu and the non-volatile
memory and we say if the command coming
from the processor will change the
behavior of the device
in a way
that is persistent we will not let it
true unless it's being signed properly
by a server that we also provide
meaning whether you're an insider
outsider or supply chain whether you're
the owner of the device whether you're a
field engineer with all the credentials
unless the software is properly signed
by the server
your commands will not go through
not only that we will stop them
and provide forensic and alerting
information at the server level to the
cso and the owner of the device if
everything is fine you can go ahead and
do this
we also developed a
technology that fits electricity
operated devices and battery operating
devices
as well as the variety of
operating systems you can find in
devices because you have all the way
from windows and linux in the higher end
but you find something called rtos
real-time operating system and even
things which are even simpler than this
in the
more than three billion smart meters out
there in the market
so that's what we do
so who does nanolog sell to so you're
you're developing this this technology
you're you're understanding about the
devices but
how does this tangibly then get into the
market and when how is analog then being
interpreted into the real world
so the guys who are benefiting from what
we do
sorry are the end customers the smart
the um
utilities
the energy companies
the industrial companies they are
benefiting from what we do and we first
sell to them
you were talking about the stakeholders
uh being the the infrastructure
companies the
you know the vendors that are then
distributing those those devices and and
are implementing them internally and we
were we left off over there sure so the
end customers are
um the end users the electricity company
the energy company the water utilities
industrial companies and so forth and
then since we need to be deployed inside
the devices the others pack us in
saying to their vendors please use an
unlock because they serve a big problem
uh they solve a big problem for us
or in some
rare
cases we work with the end
manufacturer and he brings us to the end
customer but most of the time we're
working with the end customer saying
that's what i want
dear vendor please find a solution to
work with analogs
that makes a lot of sense and obviously
and you know the market is just
beginning and we're just beginning to
understand how the how this new supply
chain is working and and you know cyber
insurance companies are just starting to
take a strong to to get a footprint into
the market and obviously they're they
have a big stake in what's happening
here the end consumers which is me i'm
at the end being impacted by the
electricity company having issues so
that you know at the end this is
impacting a lot of people and and one of
the things that i'm excited about is
understanding uh where what is the world
going to look like and how is this new
economy and this new supply chain going
to play out in the next few years
so
you
in the day-to-day now dealing with cyber
previously with nanoscience and
different companies
what are you really passionate about
what really gets you going is it the
getting things done is it the technology
what is it
um
riddle solving so once you have
so i like uh blank pages
and i like riddles
um
the more complicated drill is it's more
interesting the more
parameters which doesn't fit it's more
interesting so i i like that
um
and i like the fact that it's in it's a
blank page and then you write one word
and then you listen to the feedback
so the creation is what makes me take
that's what makes me excited
that's my passion i had a different
career in the past that was dealing
exactly with that
um
the technology is a tool the technology
has to it's an answer it's not a
question so defining the questions
defining what it is you're looking for
that's what drives me
i love it and i really want to thank you
you you're right to say that 20 minutes
is way too short and but but i'm happy
that i got to to know you better and
know analog a little bit better i want
to take you back though
with a few questions about yourself and
i want to take you back to your
childhood and understand better what
really fascinated you as a kid before
high tech before
before academy what what what really got
you going as a kid uh can i provide a
nerd alert before i do that because all
of my 100
the answer to this question will nerd me
completely
i was
passionate about
history and um and
well history
i don't have a better hand on that
well uh being a in the sixth grade
reading all the books that you could
find in the library about um yom kippur
war and having a discussion about that
and
reading everything you can know about
pre uh the three days of israel
it's nice now
uh try to have a conversation when
you're 11 with your friends in the class
about about history
i see where this is going
what inspires you today in your daily
life
um
what who inspires
me you choose
um
i'm i'm i'm well first of all i'm
inspired by nature so that's
whenever i can
i'm an avid scuba diver i do that as as
a hobby all around the world with
the specific passion for sharks and
whales
um
and i'm inspired by people who again are
asking questions and
not letting the physical boundaries stop
them
that's what excites me and and
since i spent most of my time watching
um episodes on tv on either sharks or
cosmos
season two
that's what gets me excited terribly i
love it and what are three words that
you would use to describe yourself
overweighted
um no these are two words and i'll take
it back now i'm just but i'll deal with
that i promise michael i'm working on
this too many flights um probably
passionate probably um
i would say passionate i would say uh
curious that's if i needed to find one
word that's curious so passionate
curious and and um
and and and knowledge driven
so it's four but this is the way i would
like to
describe myself
i'll take it there's a hyphen in the end
iran
thank you very very much this was
wonderful and best of luck with nanolog
security thank you for making our
devices safer and stay safe and stay
healthy so darabite was a true pleasure
and thank you for having me
you